ja wir kommen zur heutigen vorlesungen
in der wir uns mit dem thema apps
theologie der digitalität dem zweiten
teil dieser thematik befassen nachdem in
der letzten sitzung den ersten teil
davon behandelt hatten wo es um das
thema inter objektivität ging es nach
oben rechts dann wieder im youtube den
link zu dieser sitzung ein heute geht es
vor allem um den informationsbedarf auch
in technik begriff internet und trans
subjektivität das sind jetzt alle sehr
zumindest runs subjektivität wie inter
objektivität neuartige begriffsbildung
auf diese frage welche begriffe wir für
diese realität digitalität prägen müssen
werde ich noch mehr eingehen jetzt sage
ich erst mal was vorab zur gliederung
der heutige vorlesung also erstmal wie
immer ein rückblick auf die letzte
vorlesung dann möchte ich den
informations begriff nochmal stärker ins
zentrum stellen weil dieser auch mit der
app ist ökologie also der
erkenntnistheorie der frage nach der
erkenntnis nach dem wissen der
digitalität sehr eng verbunden ist dabei
werde ich auf luciano flori die eingehen
dem ich auch schon mal erwähnt hatte der
ersten vorlesung dann kommen wir auf den
begriff der einer technologie so
genannte dritter ordnung zu sprechen ich
übernehme das von luciano florida was
darunter zu verstehen ist wirklich
genauer erzählen dann kommen wir zum
eigentlichen thema der heutigen sitzung
zur app ist emol ogi des internets also
zu fragen wie das internet erkenntnis
mäßig strukturiert ist und
dann möchte ich am schluss den begriff
der trans subjektivität den ich eben
jetzt geprägt hat mal genauer erklären
und auch zur diskussion stand und dann
gibt es noch ein ausblick auf die
nächste vorlesung so jetzt dieser
rückblick zur letzten sitzung also
künstliche intelligenz war da im zentrum
gestanden und ich möchte nochmal kleinen
nachtrag bringen für diejenigen unter
ihnen die sich mehr damit
auseinandersetzen wollen mache ich noch
mal oben rechts auf den link zu einem
anderen seminar über künstliche
intelligenz hinein wo wir uns
ausführlicher mit diesen themen befassen
wir sind alle zumindest ich die
allermeisten von uns keine
informationswissenschaft und
informationswissenschaften das heißt wir
müssen uns immer fragen wie können wir
als philosophin und philosophen
kompetent über diese neuen phänomene
sprechen obwohl wir ja eine nicht
fachmänner und fachfrauen dafür sind
aber dennoch glaube ich können wir von
der philosophie kommt darüber eine
gewisse kompetente aussagen treffen und
diese aussage ist natürlich jetzt nicht
besonders technisch technologischer art
das haben wir alle die meisten wundert
nicht studiert dennoch können wir diese
strukturen mit denen wir es hier zu tun
haben im falle jetzt hier von
künstlichen neuronalen netzen
sogenannten deep learning wenn wir sie
von einer sehr allgemeinen perspektive
aus betrachtet ganz interessiert
interessante
erkenntnisse erlangen und da möchte ich
so ein paar punkte ihn auch mal nimmt
die meere gekommen sind noch mal ganz
kurz das ganz schematisch und völlig
unvollständig eine kurze beschreibung
dieses phänomens man spricht auch von
die planning die pläne ist natürlich
eine metapher tiefes lernen was bedeutet
tiefes lernen bedeutet dass bei
neuronales netz nicht nur eine intel hat
das in neuronen und eine output schicht
sind das dazwischen noch verschiedene
eine oder mehrere zwischenschichten
sogenannte versteckte schichten sind war
weil die eben nicht zu sehen sind sie
sind nicht im eingang und sind nicht im
ausgang und sie müssen sich das wie eine
blackbox vorstellen es gibt alten
eingang ausgang dazwischen passiert sehr
sehr viel hier müssen sie sich tausende
von zwischenschichten
vorstellen die einmal in den
spalten sehr sehr
reichhaltig sind also nicht nur drei
[ __ ] sind vielleicht zehntausende und
dann können sie sich vorstellen wenn sie
dann alle neuronen miteinander vernetzen
wird das mir sehr sehr komplexe
angelegenheit
das ist jetzt mal nur so eine kurze
beschreibung und jetzt möchte ich hier
mal noch auf einen weiteren punkt 1 geht
diese verbindungen zu stimmen und die
sind nicht statisch
fest stehen sondern die sind auch noch
flexibel das heißt man kann manche
verbindungen zwischen manchen neuronen
verstärken also dass da mehr information
durch geht manche kann man schwächer das
heißt man kann das ganze sehr flexibel
gestalten und diese verbindungen die
flexibel verstärkt werden könnte auch
geschwächt werden können die werden also
eigentlich nur mit einer fließkomma
stelle bezeichnet die nennt man gewicht
also das netz lernt dadurch dass die
gewichte als die verbindungen zwischen
den neuronen entweder gestärkt verstärkt
oder
geschlecht werden das heißt das wissen
dieses systems wenn man zu sagen möchte
liegt nicht so sehr in diesen rund
rinteln in dieser stärke der beziehung
zwischen diesen einzelnen
so und das ist jetzt aber noch viel zu
simpel natürlich das heißt das
entscheidende oder spannende an solchen
künstlichen neuronalen netzen oder die
learning besteht darin dass der output
nicht einfach so dann raus kommt sondern
dass der output wieder eingespeist
werden kann so sagen dass es dazu all
seiner fehler rückführung gibt also sie
haben einen sollwert sie wollen
irgendwas erreichen sie füttern das netz
darauf müssen auch noch kommen etwa sie
dass eine zu füttern und bekommen sie
ein output und diese output kann gut
oder schlecht sein gemessen an dem ziel
das leben sich vor gesetzt hat und wenn
da ein fehler rauskommt dann speisen sie
diesen fehler wieder rein all seine
fehler rückführung durch die neuronen
zurück und versuchen so dieses system
auf den fehler zu trimmen dass der
fehler möglichst gering hält man nennt
das auch
einen gradienten abstiegs verfahren also
hat dass wir mit ableitungen zu tun sehr
komplexe geschichte müssen wir gar nicht
im detail erklären wir sind hier keine
automatik vorlesungen es geht ums
prinzip das heißt das system ist auf
sich selbst bezogen es speist seit
eigenfehler wieder in sich hinein
das finde ich sehr spannend da bekommt
das ganze sondern selbst reflexen
struktur dieses bild hier habe ich auch
dass wikipedia finde ich sehr
interessant interessant finde ich also
hier nicht so sehr diese einzeln
neuronen das ist jetzt die frage wie
findest du wäre nachgebildet ist sagte
es gibt noch einen alternativen ansatz
den eher symbolischen ansatz der er mit
schlüsseln argumentierte er mit den
taktischen regeln operiert solche
neuronalen netze haben es nicht so viel
mit regeln zu tun sind einfach mit
versuch und irrtum und mit fehler
verringerung strategien und da sind so
zwei paradigmen und die künstlichen
neuronalen netze die sind in der letzten
zeit ziemlich gekommen alpha go kennen
sie habe ich schon erklärt das ist ein
komplexes programm was den weltbesten
spieler geschlagen hat indem das
programm gegen sich selbst gelernt hat
und so die regeln sich selbst
beigebracht hat also das ist eine ganz
spannende geschichte und ich glaube eben
auch das ist ein philosophischer
relevanz ist jetzt haben wir unabhängig
von der frage ob künstliche intelligenz
irgendwann die weltherrschaft übernimmt
wenn ich mir dieses trug schule anschaut
dann muss ich hier noch kein bösen
roboter befürchten oder eine reporterin
die jetzt plötzlich hier um sich schießt
oder sohn uns alle übertrifft es ist
eher eine ganz andere struktur ich
möchte auch darauf abzielen dass man
dieses netz nicht so sehr als ein
subjekt fast das hat zwar seine leicht
reflexive struktur durch zurückführen
aber es hat in einen kontext in dem es
immer eingebettet sein musste gerade
dagegen spricht es als ein akteur zu
verstehen ich werde aber auch dafür
argumentieren hab's gemacht dass wir das
künstliche neuronale netz nicht so sehr
als ein objekt oder als eine maschine
verstehen sollten das wäre wieder
lebensweltlich viel zu fremd alle müssen
mittelweg finden und dafür möchte ich
eben objekt argumentieren mit dem
begriff der inter objektivität jetzt
warte ich mal kurz damals ist haben die
philosophische bedeutung künstlicher
neuronaler netze dass es natürlich nicht
schöpfend jetzt also künstliche
neuronale netze sind selbst bezüglich
durch fehler rückführung das nennt man
auch bei papageien also das
philosophische interessante daran es
bezieht sich auf sich selbst und das ist
doch schon mal spannend und es kommt
damit irgendwie auch voran kns lernen
durch versuch und irrtum
trial and error das ist auch das prinzip
wie wir menschen lernen hat zumindest
aus evolutionsbiologischer sicht
evolutionsbiologischer sicht und es ist
spannend also es macht das ganz ähnlich
wie wir und die gewichtungen die
zwischen den neuronen beherrschen die
repräsentieren das wissen da ist
irgendwas gespeichert was bleibt was
immer stabilen das system spielt sich
ein manche sprechen sogar davon dass das
künstliche neuronale netz nicht nur
wissen besitzen eine urteilskraft
besitzt finde ich ganz spannend kann man
nochmal genauer darauf eingehen also
jetzt muss man aber auch dazu sagen und
das führt mich weg von diese sicht auf
kann es im sinne von zu blicken nämlich
operieren diese systeme immer nur auf
basis von menschlichen informationen es
muss gefüttert werden niemals schön mit
davor gesagt und es wird sicher nicht
selbst mit irgendwas man muss ihm etwas
liefern es kann damit dann zwar
verschiedene dinge tun jetzt rede ich
wieder so als seien zuletzt aber damit
möchte ich sagen es benötigt zwecke die
ihn vorgegeben werden und zwar von außen
es selbst setzen keine zwecke und das
deutet wiederum eher auf eine hetero mit
struktur hin oder wenn man es anders
formulieren möchte auf eine hypothetisch
also bedingte autonom ihren ich sagte
keine sind eine hypothetische autonomen
ihre operationen und jetzt lassen sie
sich aber darauf kommt es mir an wenn
man sie nicht als akteure verstehen aber
auch nicht nur als maschinen lassen sie
sich in die lebenswelt in die
systemische lebenswelt einbeziehung
unserer menschlichen interessen sie
lassen sich mit unseren zielen
verletzten und ganz wichtig scheint mir
zu sein dass eben unsere interessen
unser wissen durch diese datenbasis auf
den diese netze zu greifen immer schon
mit einfließen in die ergebnisse
deswegen greift auch in meinen augen ein
bild ein black box begriff von
künstlichen neuronalen netzen zu kurz
wir wissen zwar wirklich nicht genau was
im inneren vorgeht wir könnten es
theoretisch gerechnet aber es ist viel
zu komplex dass die sich wirklich lohnen
würde dennoch es geht darin nicht
irgendwas vor sich was sich gänzlich
unsere erkenntnis entzieht sondern die
prozesse die darin vorgehen sind so
strukturiert dass sie fehler reduzieren
und das system sich auf sich selbst
beziehen und das finde ich immerhin
schon etwas was interessant ist und was
gegen eine bloße reduktionistischen
blackbox theorie von künstlichen
neuronalen netzen spricht
das heißt künstliche intelligenz und das
lässt sich einfach nicht mehr von der
hand weisen wird immer mehr teil unserer
lebenswelt ohne dass sie die
weltherrschaft an sich reißen das wäre
eine ideologisierung eine übertreibung
und ich glaube dass deswegen der begriff
der mensch-maschine-interaktion nicht
mehr angemessen ist wir haben sie nicht
mit einer maschine zu tun so sind hebel
umlegen die maschine ist immer so ein
objekt was uns gegenüber steht und das
scheint mit dieser neuen form von
künstlicher intelligenz im verbunden mit
dem internet immer weniger der fall sein
künstliche intelligenz findet überall
statt vernetzt sich immer mehr mit uns
smart home smart watch handy uns weiter
deswegen sollten wir wie ich schon sagte
kann nicht im sinne eines subjekts oder
objekts verstehen sondern als prozess
und intelligenz leistungen und diese
intelligenz leistung die immer natürlich
für uns abhängt lässt sich unsere
lebenswelt integrieren und mit anderen
menschlichen operation nahtlos
vernetzten dieses nahtlose dieses
reibungslose von dem auch luciano
frieden spricht scheint mir dafür ganz
zentral zu sein
wenn man jetzt als auf kali nicht mehr
subjekt oder objekt theoretisch am
operationstisch
beim reflektiert so wird es möglich
diese neuronalen netz sind ihre
operation weise jenseits von klose
simulation oder duplikation zu verstehen
nämlich im sinne virtuelle realität auf
diesen begriff den ich immer schon
wieder ein paar vorlesungen verwendet
hat wie werde ich in den nächsten
vorlesung ausführlich eingehen weiler
von vielen missverständnissen geprägt
ist viele würden sagen virtuelle
realität ist doch nichts anderes als
simulation das glaube ich eben gerade
nicht
nicht nur eine bloße spielerei
simulation ist es aber auch keine
künstliche intelligenz im sinne eines
menschlichen zügen was da plötzlich
aufsteht oder uns sogar bedroht nein es
ist einfach ein prozess der sich in
unserer lebenswelt immer besser
integrieren lässt das heißt müssen karl
jenseits des support x-mas verstehen und
hierfür bietet sich in meinen augen mit
kräfte inter objektivität in der
objektivität bedeutet dass es ein netz
gibt ein kontext auch im internet von
gründen und zielen den wir vorgeben der
aber durch die ki weiter dynamisiert und
verstärkt wird das heißt wir gehen immer
in die intelligenz leistung des
neuronalen netzes mit ein weil wir die
datengrundlage und ich möchte ein
beispiel bringt sie kennen vielleicht
die pal also die language learning
dieses
exzellente
übersetzungsprogramm was sie kostenlos
verwenden können dieses
übersetzungsprogramm was alle anderen
übersetzungsprogramme übertrifft
argumentiert aber oder existiert auf
basis einer extrem großen datenbasis
aber wir alle tragen zu dieser
datenbasis zu indem wir zum beispiel
dieses programm befragen und füttern das
heißt wir sind es eigentlich dahinter
stehen aber eben nicht mehr individuell
wir können nicht mehr direkt
nachvollzogen werden sollen wir gehen
irgendwie ein aber daneben im sinne
dieser informations logik der inter
objektivität jetzt habe ich den begriff
der informationen schon ein paarmal
gebracht die müssen jetzt genauer
bestimmen hier erscheint mir dieses buch
von luciano flori die die vierte
revolution besonders zentral zu sein das
kann nicht wirklich sehr empfehlen ein
paar jahren erschienen ich zeige ihnen
noch ein bild und diesen autos
was meint ihr jetzt mit diesem vierten
revolution es geht um die informations
revolution ich zitiere mal dieses buch
handelt von den auswirkungen die unsere
digitalen informations und
kommunikationstechnologien darauf haben
wie wir uns selbst verstehen die wir
miteinander in beziehung treten und wie
wir unsere welt gestalten und mit der
interaktive nanotechnologie das internet
der dinge web 2.0 semantisches web cloud
computing computerspiele mit
bewegungserfassung
smartphone-apps tablet-computer und
touchscreen gps augmented reality
künstliche begleiter unbemannte drohnen
fahrerlose autos bärbl staiger
identitätsdiebstahl onlinekurse soziale
medien cyberkrieg techno viele und
techno vorbestellen sich dieselbe frage
was kommt als nächstes
also führt hier ziemlich viele
technologien an
informationstechnologien wir müssen
jetzt diese art von technik genauer
verstehen
flori die schreibweise der philosoph und
die philosophin fragen sich was steckt
dahinter gibt es eine verbindende
perspektive aus der sich alle diese
neueren phänomene man kann auch sagen
die neuen medien als aspekte eines
einzigen makroskopischen trends
interpretieren lassen schwer zu
beantworten ist die frage auch deshalb
weil wir nach wie vor gewohnt sind in
diesen technologien werkzeuge zur
interaktion mit der welt und mit uns
selbst zu verstehen in wahrheit sind aus
ihnen umwelt gestaltete anthropologisch
sozial und interpretativen kräftigen sie
schaffen und prägen unsere geistige und
materielle wirklichkeit verändern unser
selbstverständnis modifizieren wie wir
miteinander in beziehung treten und uns
auf uns selbst beziehen und sie bringen
unsere welt deutet auf einen neuen
besseren stand und das tun sie eben so
tiefgreifend wie umfassend und um
unablässig sie sehen eher florida ist
ein optimist er sagt sie bringen unsere
weltdeutung auf einen besser stand das
kann man natürlich auch kritisieren also
floride wird sicherlich nicht als ein
techno voba philosoph sondern ein techno
vieler philosoph zu gelten haben und man
muss sich jetzt fragen ist diese
optimistische einschätzung
gerechtfertigt müssen auch fragen auf
welcher ebene überhaupt diese frage an
diese neuen medien adressieren dürfen
und das scheint mir ganz entscheidendes
zeit jetzt gibt hier floridis sein ziel
des buches noch mal kurz an in diesem
buch sagte skizziere ich lediglich ein
paar ideen seine philosophie der
information entweder in form einer
philosophie der hyper geschichte ist
eine philosophie der natur in form einer
philosophie der infos wäre für eine
philosophische anthropologie in form
einer 14 revolution in unserem
selbstverständnis nach der
kopernikanischen ist die erste der
darwinschen der zweiten und der
freudschen revolution und vereine
philosophie der politik in form der
entwicklung von multi akteurs systeme
die sich der aufgabe globale probleme zu
bewältigen gewachsen sein können also
florida versucht mit dem begriff der
information und infos fähre diese ganzen
phänomene der neuen medien in ein
umfassendes dann wir sagt
makroskopischen trend zu integrieren und
hier eine generelle theorie dieser neuen
medien zu formulieren dafür ist eben für
ihn der informations begriff entscheiden
ich persönlich finde es sehr sympathisch
so einen generellen zugang zu wählen der
nicht nur in einzelnen phänomen
technologischer art ansätzen den genauen
überblick versucht zu schaffen ich
glaube eben nur dass der informations
begriff dafür zu schwach ist glaube
damit kommen wir nicht weit genug um
diese von ihm in meinen augen völlig
richtig gezeigten konsequenzen adäquat
philosophisch zu begreifen und zu
bestimmen und jetzt geht es genau um
diese frage wie können wir diese
phänomene diesen neuen adäquat begreift
das heißt es geht um die frage wie ich
begriffe wir dass wir verwenden müssen
auch hier sagt floride was da zu dem
buch ich zitiere nochmal schließlich
werden sie die leser bei der lektüre
dieses buches feststellen dass es eine
menge nur vorläufige oder versuchsweise
verwendete begriffe um termini enthält
zusammen mit neologismen agronomen und
fachausdrücken wie zum beispiel auch die
info sphäre einer ist dergleichen
versuche zur umgestaltung unserer
sprache können ärgerlich seien sie
lassen sich jedoch nicht immer vermeiden
mein ringen um eine balance zwischen
lesbarkeit und genauigkeit ist
offensichtlich und ich habe mich
entschlossen es nicht zu verbergen genau
wie ein guter schwimmer in der lage ist
stromaufwärts zu schwimmen sollte ein
gut hast du ja so schon eine gute
philosophin die schwierige kunst
beherrschen sprach aufwärts zu denken
gegen den strom sprachlicher gefunden
ich teile diese ansicht unbedingt bin
mir jedoch auch darüber im klaren dass
meine bemühungen um die erfassung des
umfassenden tiefgreifend 9 mit dem wir
es in geistiger hinsicht zu tun haben
unzureichend bleibt erst jetzt wir haben
es hier mit einem tief greifen neuen zu
tun und das neue muss natürlich mit
neuen begriffen verstanden werden also
anders formuliert die herkömmlichen
begriffe die wir haben lebens wirklich
aber auch philosophisch die reichen nach
florida nicht mehr aus und dieses neu zu
fassen ich würde flori die hier auf
jeden fall zustimmen hab ja auch hier
schon ein anfang gemacht mit inter
objektivität oder trans subjektivität in
der heutigen krise das scheint mit
entscheidende frage ist seit 1 1 bin ich
mit flori die darin was jetzt das
paradigma ist für das verständnis dieses
neuen ist es wirklich nur die
technologie oder die information dass
müssen wir genauer klären jetzt bringt
hier florida einen interessanten begriff
ins spiel auch so eine art neologismus
oder zumindest eine neue war begriffs
schöpfung die technologien dritter
ordnung und das möchte ich auch noch mal
kurz beschreiben oder erklären was
florida mit meint weil wir ja immer wenn
wir die neuen medien behandelt uns
fragen müssen wir hängen das mit dem
informations begriff zusammen und wie
hängt es auch mit dem technik begriff
zusammen ich hatte schon meine these
geäußert dass ich glaube dass die
technik philosophie nicht mehr alleine
zuständig ist wird diese neuen phänomene
für dieses tief greifend neu und zwar
deswegen weil es eben nicht mehr nur als
technik wahrgenommen das neue medium
sondern als ein lebens wirkliches
phänomen jetzt müssen natürlich fragen
was er meint ist technologie dritter
orden erst müssen wir fragen was mein
technologie erster ordnung und ein
zweiter ordnung und dann schließlich
dritter ordnung jetzt geht erstmal um
die technologie erste ort und er sagt in
diesem buch befinden sich die
technologien zwischenmenschlichen
anwendern um natürlich auslösen können
wir sie mehr bestimmt als technologien
erster ordnung die axt ist vermutlich
die erste und älteste art der
technologie erster ordnung eine axt zum
holz spalten ist heute noch genauso wie
eine technologie erste auch zwischen
einem menschen dem anwender und dem aus
dem ausland also das holz ist der
natürliche auslese ein sattel befindet
sich zwischen der person und einem pferd
nagelknipser und jagd sind andere fälle
solche technologien erster ordnung als
sie zielen auf etwas natürlich gegeben
es hin unsere fingernägel oder das pferd
oder die beute das will ja
die diese erster ordnung müssen nicht
unbedingt simpel sein um die sowohl
technologie abhängig als auch technisch
ausgefeilt sein können wie das beispiel
eines sturmgewehrs zeigt bei dem es sich
um eine technologie erste orten zwischen
zwei seiten handelt auf dem als anwender
und als auslöser leider jeweils menschen
stehen also das sind für ihn
technologien ihres zu orten mit der axt
würde es ziemlich klar dass sie eine
naturressourcen gearbeitet wird also
ziemlich unmittelbare natur kontakt
jetzt geht es um die technologien
zweiter ordnung ein motor verstanden als
jede technologie die andere technologien
mit energie versorgt ist wohl die
wichtigste technologie zweiter ordnung
jahrtausendelang haben wassermühlen und
windenergie nützliche bewegung
umgewandelt doch erst als aus der
dampfmaschine dem verbrennungsmotor und
ein elektromotor
tragbar energieversorger werden die sich
zwischen nutzer und andere technologien
platzieren lassen wo auch immer bedarf
besteht nimmt die industrie ihre würze
und fahrt auf und verbreitet sich über
den globus also das ganze wird viel
mobiler und unmittelbare es wird viel
ausgreifender und dabei handelt es sich
um eine technologie zweiter und jetzt
kommen wir schließlich zur technologie
dritter ordnung
einschließlich des internets der d die
sind im grunde dabei uns die
schwerfälligen menschlichen zwischen
wesen aus der schleife zu entfernen in
einer der fragmentierten und
vollintegrierten infos fähre wird die
unsichtbare koordination dieser geräte
untereinander so reibungslos
funktionieren wie das zusammenspiel
zwischen ihren smartphone und ihrem
laptop und zwischen diesem und dem
drucker es ist schwer vorherzusagen was
passieren wird wenn die dinge sich unter
das austauschen werden doch ich wäre
nicht überrascht wenn computer und
software unternehmen in naher zukunft
geräte anwendungen entwickeln und
vertreiben würden ihr fernseher
angeschlossen naja also smart home und
so ist jetzt ja auch nicht so
so neue schon also was florida sagt kies
wird immer mehr zur realität und das ist
in meinen augen gestreut dass immer mehr
geräte miteinander vernetzt werden und
das ist ihm gerade auch das phänomen
tinter objektivität das zusammenspiel
und die vollintegrierte infos wäre die
defragmentiert ist die völlig
reibungslos organisiert ist die hat
florida in meinen augen sehr sehr
treffend geprägt die frage ist nur mit
welchen begriff wir diese infos fähre
verstehen soll ich glaube dass der
informationsbedarf zu schwach ist ich
glaube dass die beliebte virtuellen
realität dafür die einzig angemessene
okay geben noch mal kurz auf die dritte
ordnungs technologie ein die digitale
online welt weitet sich in die analoge
offline welt hinein aus und verschmilzt
mit ihr dieses jüngste phänomen verwirrt
unter diversen bezeichnungen wie
ubiquitär es computing umgebungs
intelligenz das internet der dinge oder
weg auf web meldet singles die
erweiterung der dinge durch das netz ich
verwende dafür lieber den ausdruck
onlive erfahrung sie ist oder wird das
nächste studium stadium der entwicklung
im informationszeitalter sein wir leben
immer mehr ein onlive finde ich ihn sehr
guten begriff weil er zeigt dass hier
das online was sie ein zustand ist ein
technischer zustand ich bin online
offenheit dass der eben gerade
lebensweltlich gewendet wird integriert
wird und dafür wird ein neuer begriff
geprägt online finde ich also genau
richtig genau so muss man die begriffe
prägen um diesen neuen realitäten die
ich wie für virtuelle realität eine alte
nicht für informationstechnologien
gerecht zu werden so jetzt kommen wir
zur epidemiologie des internets nachdem
ich ein bisschen was an einem theorie
dieses info sphäre begriff zum
informations und technologie begriff
gesagt habe also das internet und das
würde ich jetzt eben nochmal hinzufügen
zu floridas ist das paradigma von
technologien dritter ordnung ich gehe
sogar noch einen schritt weiter dass der
technologische aspekte im internet immer
weiter zurück tritt das internet ist
keine technologie dritter orden es wäre
viel zu technologisch technokratisch
gesehen da hat es ja schon eigentlich
gezeigt das internet ist etwas was mit
unserem leben zu tun hat also nicht mehr
nur eine technologie das internet ist
nicht zu sehr technologie oder ein
medium als vielmehr ein virtueller
handlungsrahmen aber auch ein virtueller
erkenntnis warum es ist ja auch noch
ganz wichtig mentale gehalt ideen
gedanken meine gefühle die eigentlich
nur subjektiven charakter haben werden
durch die hypertext würdest du hast
dieses verbindende dieses reibungslose
integrierte des internets aufgenommen
und vom individuum abgelöst welches
sicher vorgebaut hat das kann man jetzt
wieder als inter objektivität
beschreiben man kann es aber auch wie
hier zum heutigen vorlesung tun möchte
als trans zur aktivität
ich komme noch genauer darauf zu
sprechen das internet hat als eine
gewissermaßen eine transzendente tendenz
es die in seiner richtung her vom
intranet von etwas abgekapselten zum
internet als hatten sich die tendenz
alle grenzen zu überschreiten und alles
miteinander zu vernetzen alles
miteinander in beziehung zu setzen das
finde ich interessant das internet
besitzt und es auch nicht interessanter
punkt eine epidemische eigenlogik die
vor allem mit dem suchen nach
informationen zu tun hat also den jetzt
genau eine app ist ökologie des
internets wickeln wollen müssen wir
fragen wie wir überhaupt im internet zum
wissen kommen weil im internet des
werden sie alle gemerkt haben die
information nicht einfach so offen zu
tage liegen oder nicht einfach
unvermittelt zu tage treten soll eine
ganz große vermittlungsleistung immer
schon haben wie sieht bei uns ankommt
und diese vermittlungsleistung oder
diese vermittelnde informations logik
müssen wir nochmal genauer behandelt
dazu habe ich ein interessantes zitat
die autorinnen nicht gleich die jetzt
auf die frage ein geht wie wir im
internet überhaupt zur kenntnis ohne zu
informationen kommen
dieser diese text den ich ihnen jetzt
zieht ihre ist aus dem jahr 2000 sie
werden das gleich mehr dennoch halte ich
ihn für sehr aktuell ist also über 20
jahren alt die bisher gesammelten
erfahrungen mit den großen letzten im
internet erlauben schon heute zu
beobachten dass das modell des archivs
dafür unangemessen ist alle versuche
feste orientierungs mittel vorzubereiten
in der form von gelben zeit
verzeichnissen adressen sammlung oder
einfach internet führung werden sofort
obsolet die einzigen wirksamen mittel
sind die sogenannten search engines
suchmaschinen wie yahoo
lycos altavista webcrawler und so weiter
jetzt kann ich sie frage woran sehen sie
dass dieser text nicht aktuell sehen es
daran dass wir google nicht erwähnt wird
diese ganzen suchmaschine altavista gibt
es vielleicht noch aber fast niemand
möchte jetzt die mal zu nahetreten
genutzt sie nach google ist schon sehr
dominant ist aber nur eine frage der
zeit bis es vielleicht wieder eine
andere suchmaschine wird unter umständen
hier geht es ums prinzip es geht darum
dass die information nicht alles einfach
präsentiert werden sondern müssen sie
über verschiedene zwischen inzwischen
medien müssen wir sie auf suchen diese
mittel sind eine art software maschinen
die über keine registrierten
informationen verfügen sind die antwort
auf die gestellten fragen jeweils neu
produzieren oder berechnet die antwort
ist als immer an das nicht nur weil das
netz sich ständig verändert sind auch
weil die informationen die man gewinnt
von der abfrage des benutzers abhängig
sind und es kann repertoire gibt mit
schnee voraus vorgegebenen antworten die
suchmaschine orientiert sich jeweils an
der gestellten frage also an dem jeweils
aktuellen kontext und wählt dann so aus
dass die relevanten inhalte für den
betreffenden fall produziert werden
können ich möchte das jetzt sogar noch
ein bisschen radikalisieren was sie die
autorin lena ist pastor in ihrem aufsatz
der zu recht sagt ich würde folgendes
sagen suchen und finden hängen in der
epidemiologie des internets aufs engste
miteinander zusammen weil ich finde
immer mehr das was ich suche also meinen
suchbegriff hat immer einfluss auf was
sich dann finde es gibt eine ganz enge
vernetzung zwischen suchen und finden
wenn viele nutzer des internets nutzerin
nutzer ein bestimmter begriff suchen
dann wird dieser begriff system ish
durch seine sucht intentional i tät
aufgewertet und immer prominent das hat
natürlich auch verschiedene probleme die
damit sich zieht zum beispiel die
blasenbildung auf die comic noch genauer
zu sprechen also dieser text ist über 20
jahre alt dennoch total aktuell
ja das heißt wir müssen jetzt konkret
die auch die frage nach der piste
mission existenz im internet stellen
wann existiert im internet etwas
gefunden werden kann was da überhaupt
eine information ist gilt etwa der
slogan ich werde gefunden also bin ich
ja wurde ich werde gesucht also bin ich
oder umgedreht ich werde nicht gefunden
also bin ich nicht ich werde nicht
gesucht also bin ich nicht es hat schon
ein bisschen was davon wenn man eben
nach etwas sucht und es gibt es nicht
oder man kriegt keine antwort auf das
kann ganz verschiedene gründe haben
warum es kein output gibt aber man ist
immer mehr dazu geneigt dann davon
auszugehen dass es das nicht gibt wenn
dieses ganze große internet keine
rückantwort gibt auf meine suchanfrage
dann scheinen der schluss nahe dass es
das nicht gibt also wie kopf schließen
hier von dem systemischen suchbegriff
von den gefundenen oder nicht gefunden
beginnt auf seine existenz ist ein
übergang zu ontologie zu finden das
hatte ich schon gesagt die suchanfrage
generiert auch das suchergebnis als
suche und gesuchtes oder
ausgegebenes sind in der logik der
epidemischen mobiles internet
aufeinander bezogen und das ist in der
anderen apps technologie der regel nicht
so das heißt durch den einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz kommen wir immer
mehr zu der gefahr einer blasenbildung
am ende wird mir nur noch das
ausgespuckt das angezeigt was ich immer
schon finden möchte also es kommt dann
zu einer art selbsterfüllende
prophezeihung und ich habe keinen
wirklichen maßstab mehr objektiven
maßstab an dem die suche dann auch
orientiert werden kann ja das ist das
problem dieser verstärkenden künstlichen
intelligenz ist möchte ich als ein
problem nennen das ist natürlich
ausgeschlossen dass sich künstliche
intelligenz auch so einsetzen lässt dass
ich auch viele andere dinge tun die
vielleicht gerade den suchbegriffen
entgegengesetzt sind ich glaube dass sie
auch kommerzielle interessen ein grund
sind für diese blasenbildung das lässt
sich schön kommerziell ist ish
ausschlachten das ist ein kritikpunkt
auf denen ich an in den dann noch in
einer gewissen ethischen ausblick
eingehen möchte dh bis technologie des
internets ist anfang andere art als
unsere gewöhnlichen bis technologien
unseres wissens theorien zur theorien
von wissenserwerb überhaupt müsste man
die frage stellen inwiefern es sich beim
internet überhaupt um einen wissen
handelt ich glaube es handelt sich und
wissens gegenständen wissen aber viel
genau ist schon viel vernetzter wir
brauchen so meine these eine eigene
hermeneutik das internet also eine
theorie des verstehens des internets und
diese hermeneutik die einen teil einer
app is technologie sein muss die muss
eine frage und such logik kanal muss
also besonders auf das phänomen des
fragens und des suchens und auch das
finden es im internet reflektieren was
von völlig verschiedene art ist als das
überwiegend lebensweltliche suchen
finden nach bestimmten gegenständen ihr
geht es nicht so sehr um gegenstände
weil wir mit diesen gegenständen immer
durch den begriff der inter objektivität
vernetzt sind also hier sieht man wieder
inter objektivität alles hängt
miteinander zusammen
es ist nicht so wie ein solo an der
geldbeutel der mir irgendwann dann
wieder auftaucht oder fundbüro abgegeben
wird nein diese informationen nach denen
ich suche die hängen mit mir viel enger
zusammen als deckel beutel in dem sich
mein personalausweis befindet ist tot
das heißt das internet ist die medial
verein ein repräsentatives netz medial
fanden im idealfall repräsentiert das
internet internet unsere physikalische
physische welt unsere analoge welt ist
ein up bilder vom idealfall ist
natürlich nicht der fall den faktor
und daraus folgt durch den begriff des
onlive den frieden mein auge sehr
treffend begibt geprägt hat dass das
internet nicht nur zu einem
grundbedürfnis wird sondern eigentlich
auch normative bedeutung erlangt und zu
einem grundrecht avancieren wird da bin
ich überzeugt
das scheint mir eine unausweichliche
entwicklung zu sein weil es eben alles
wenn man das jetzt und weil eben gemäß
dieser logik ich werde gefunden also bin
ich
diese vernetzung immer bedeutsamer
werden wird jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen
inwiefern
dieses grundbedürfnis nach einem
internet nicht als eine sucht
verstanden werden muss das würde jetzt
manfred spitzer tun sicherlich ich
glaube das wird dem internet im sinne
des online es überhaupt nicht gerecht
der begriff des online ives bedeutet
nicht dass ich den ganzen tag im
internet kennen und dann nicht mehr
davon los komme eigentlich irgendwelche
computerspielen spiel und da abhängig
werden im gegenteil das internet ist
einfach teil der lebenswelt und
verfliest mit ihr verläuft mit ihr es
ist kein
normativer begriff der begriff des
onlive sondern ein deskriptive ist
einfach nur mit tatsachen die gar nichts
mit der sucht zu tun hat das sieht man
auch schon daran dass viele menschen
immer mehr im home office arbeiten wir
bekommen wieder mehr die situation jetzt
durch diese nächste welle leider sage
ich aber das wird dann nicht als sucht
verstanden werden wenn ein mensch sein
geld über home office im internet
verdienen das ist keine sucht das ist
ein alltägliches phänomen und ohne dass
unsere gesellschaft nicht existieren
könnte
jetzt möchte ich einen kurzen ausgegeben
der jetzt ihren richtung eine ethik des
internets weiß darauf werde ich auch
noch einmal eigens in einer vorlesung zu
sprechen kommen wir nicht das internet
als einen virtuellen handlungsraum genau
diskutieren werde ich glaube wir
brauchen in zukunft zumindest möglich
dass zur debatte stellen eigentlich eine
demokratisch gewählte internet regierung
die
wegkommt von diesem kommerziellen
für dieser kommerziellen
strukturiertheit immer wieder kommt dann
die debatte darauf aber das internet ist
doch kontrolliert entstehen der ruhr
marktinteressen im zentrum gerade dann
wenn es zu dieser blasen bekommt das mir
immer wieder dinge vorgeschlagen werden
wenn ich einmal danach gesucht hat klar
diese blasenbildung ist in meinen augen
mit mittels der künstliche intelligenz
kommerziell ist ish kommerziell
orientiert das ist aber nicht so dass
das unbedingt zu sein müsste ich glaube
es gibt eine form eine ideale form des
internets in dem diese blasenbildung
nicht existiert das heißt ich plädiere
und ich glaube auch dass man das in form
einer ethik des internets tun sollte für
eine reduzierung der kommerzialisierung
sicherlich kann das internet auch ein
raum des kommerzes seien aber in seiner
grundstruktur sollte ist das nicht sein
und dann kann man die frage stellen ist
das internet gegen jetzt so eine tendenz
eine internet regierung wikipedia weist
in meinen augen ein bisschen diese
richtung hin aufgrund seiner recht
demokratische art und weise
informationen zu generieren
oder sollte man sagen nein das internet
ist der letzte hort das positiv
anhaltischen gebrauchen diana chemie
wird alles andere zu viel
reglementierung beschränkt die
kreativität des internets bin ich offen
bin ich noch nicht ganz entschieden
müssen wir diskutieren wie man diesen
rahmen diesen politischen rahmen des
internets den wir irgendwann mal
definieren müssen zu fassen
also gesagt das internet wird immer mehr
zu einer lebensform onlive und ich würde
eben sagen zu einer virtuellen realität
jenseits harmlose sucht sucht
therapeutischer
diagnostiziert wie wir sie bei manfred
spitzer finden so das war jetzt mal eine
kurze zusammenfassung ich und meine
theorie zur interesse objektivität und
transsexualität ich möchte jetzt noch
ganz kurz ein ausblick auf die nächste
sitzung geben und zwar ist die dann dem
thema also nicht der neuen sinn ist an
der sechsundzwanzigster ist sie dann dem
thema ontologie der digitalität gewidmet
und hier steht dann besonders im zentrum
die frage was virtuelle realität ist ich
bin der meinung und darauf werde
ausführlich noch zu sprechen kann
virtuelle realität ist nicht simulation
ist nicht nur eine spielerei ist nicht
nur was mit 3d brille was wir auf dem
kopf haben sondern der betrieb der
virtuellen realität beschreibt diese
realität näher mit der wir ist hier zum
beispiel auch im falle des urlaubs zu
tun hat nämlich eine realität die aber
eben virtueller artist und nicht
körperlich art des dennoch ist sie nicht
weniger real das ist so die these und
darauf müssen heute noch genauso
sprechen kommt weil die ontologie der
digitalität im grunde genommen alles
fundiert alles was in dieser dritten
technologie revolution der info sphäre
und der digitalität zu tun hat ja dann
bedanke ich mich für die aufmerksamkeit
und bin gespannt auf die diskussion